bell martin et l' affaire du sang
contaminé c'est donc les pilotes d'un
des plus grands scandales sanitaires et
politiques de ces dernières années la
cour de cassation confirme le non-lieu
général en faveur des trente personnes
médecins ou conseillers ministériels
mise en examen une décision accueillie
par des cris et des larmes sur place
dominique verdeilhan gilles jacquier
aucune illusion
aucun espoir les familles des victimes
n'avaient aucun doute c'est la fin d'un
combat de 15 ans alors leur colère
explose dans la salle à l'intention des
magistrats
honte à vous vous êtes des vendus des
lâches dehors la révolte de février
il ya une faillite judiciaire c'est
foutu notre pays est foutu à déterminer
au japon ils se sont agenouillés et nous
droits de l'homme on n'est pas capable
d'aller jusqu'au procès mais c'est une
honte
la cour de cassation a donc suivi
l'avocat général le dossier
définitivement refermé aucun crime
aucun délit ne peut être retenue contre
les 30 mise en examen
écoutez et ouvert un dossier pour nous
dire bagnard ya dégagé est rien on ne
saura jamais quels ont été les
responsables de cette affaire et surtout
on ne tirera pas les leçons de cette
tragédie
c'est ça qui de mon point de vue de
rendre un non lieu qui sauve donc d'un
procès michel garretta déjà jugé déjà
condamné mais aussi du chef vers l'ex
directeur de cabinet de laurent fabius
et françois gros l'ex directeur de
l'institut pasteur
alors les victimes s'en prennent
violemment aux avocats de la défense
rien on doit les airs offrir c'est un
crime et on devait juger mais c'est une
histoire de gros sous
peut-être ne fallait-il pas continuer de
faire croire à celles et ceux qui
étaient dans la douleur des victimes
qu'il y avait du côté des décideurs
politiques en particulier et des tueurs
et je crois qu'il y avait là le terme
n'était pas trop fort une forme de
tromperie
les associations craignent que ce point
final touchent par ricochet les autres
dossiers sanitaire actuellement à
l'instruction
c'est le but de cet arrêt c'est par
effet domino empêcher la justice de
pouvoir passer dans les affaires
sanitaires et encore une fois ça aura de
très grands risques par ce cas ci il y
aura forcément de nouveaux morts face au
palais des militants d'act up apporte un
ultime soutien à des victimes
déboussolés